[Music]
for more than 75 years the United States
and Russia have been the primary players
in the nuclear arms race
[Music]
the two Global Powers still possess 90
percent of the world's nuclear warheads
2011 they've abided by an agreement
limiting both their nuclear warheads and
the missiles that deliver them
ratifying a treaty like start isn't
about winning a victory for an
Administration or a political party
it's about the Safety and Security of
the United States of America
the Russian ambassador to the U.S says
given the war in Ukraine it would be
impruded to allow the American Military
onto its soil Russia says it will honor
the treaty's other terms
even so this has generated fear in the
U.S that the new start treaty could
collapse before it expires in 2026.
meanwhile the number of acknowledged
nuclear States remains small but nuclear
know-how is spreading that means
treaties like the new start May no
longer be the most urgent topic on the
non-proliferation agenda
foreign
the government maintains it would only
use a nuclear weapon if attacked or
facing a major threat some analysts
believe going forward the country will
rely more on what's called non-strategic
nuclear weapons with shorter ranges as
it did during the 1970s and 80s
crises between Russia and the US in the
past have been averted through diplomacy
but with relations between the NATO
alliance and Moscow on edge over the war
in Ukraine much will be needed if that's
to be achieved again Natasha ganim Al
Jazeera
nuclear arms control specialist he was
director of the disarmament arms control
and non-proliferation program at
Stockholm International Peace Research
Institute is joining us now from Vienna
thanks very much indeed for being with
us is it a surprise that Russia would
decide to back out out of certain parts
of this treaty given what is going on in
the world at the moment
well I think we should understand that
there have been no Stark inspections for
the past two years because both sides
agreed that because of covid-19 it would
not be possible to send inspectors now a
few weeks ago the United States
approached the Russian Federation asking
it to resume inspections which have been
suspended for two years and as your
correspondent pointed out the Russian
position at the moment is that given the
ongoing War it would not be possible to
have a U.S inspect coming on to Russian
soil however in the latest data exchange
which the United States state department
has posted on its website the Russians
are within the limits of new start which
means that they have less than 1550
strategic warheads and less than 700
deployed intercontinental ballistic
missiles and bombers
so help me with some context here they
they does everything hinge on the
inspections because as Natasha was
mentioning before Russia says it will
honor other parts of of the treaty
yes so both sides routinely exchange
data on the number of deployed strategic
nuclear warheads and the number of
deployed Delivery Systems what the
on-site inspections do is to verify that
the Declarations made by each side are
in fact correct and the number of
nuclear warheads and missiles are within
the limits of the new starting so as
long as the Russians and Americans
continue to do the data exchanges which
they do every six months the United
States also has National Technical means
which is using satellites to observe
Russian storage sites and missile
deployment sites so Americans have a
pretty good idea of what the Russians
have and vice versa one of the concerns
since the start of the Ukraine war has
been the possibility that Russia might
threaten to use a limited range nuclear
tactical nuclear weapon in the
battlefields of Ukraine now to somebody
like myself who doesn't understand the
machinations of this kind of treaty how
would this lack of oversight if you like
by the U.S contribute to any possibility
of of that happening
well these inspections would not really
uh show uh whether or not the Russians
were intending to use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine or anywhere else as the United
States has already said despite the
statements made by Moscow the United
States has not yet observed reparations
for Russian nuclear missiles or bombers
leaving their normal deployment sites
nor have they seen any heightened alert
for the nuclear weapons in Russia and
I'm sure the United States would
announce a word that you see such signs
of Russia preparing to use nuclear
weapons we really appreciate you giving
us the benefit of your expertise in this
so take RAV thank you very much indeed
for your time
you